[Musik]
ja nix ermöglichen wir stadtklinik wie
es läuft aber jetzt mache ist einfach
jamin rang lange vorbereitet schwer es
auch einfach sagen wie sehr kundige mehr
geld das wir so dass im internet
inzwischen dort konkret sind oder die
jetzt wieder präpariert ist konkret und
spezielles gefühl
oder mein geschirr mit dem das tier kann
eine tote menschen ja komisch so hugo
gretler spezielles gefühl
kevin hüfner ist mit 16 der jüngste
bestatter der schweiz und führt bereits
sein eigenes bestattungsunternehmen kann
das gut gehen
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
mit 16 darf kevin den leichenwagen noch
nicht selber fahren
dafür hat er einen mitarbeiter seien 30
mobil hingegen schon in meinem kopf die
immer wiederkehrende frage wie kommt ein
teenager auf die idee bestattet zu
werden wegen der fernsehserie sein
jahren im jahr verhindert ist jeder
beruf
der mit sehr schmal kontakt kommen
dort ist der boxster fertigung haben
abläuft das so geht der monat steigen
er wollte sich bei erfahrenen bestattern
ausbilden lassen
aber er bekam nur absagen dann machte er
sich selbständig
nun hat er ein geschäft in lyss und biel
sein ziel neuen wind ins bestatter wesen
bringen
es sei ja nicht schwarz donko und ist
dort ich hasse schock nur bongo bisher
vielfach natürlicher und freundliche
diese branche basiert auf tradition
alteingesessene bekommen die mehrheit
der aufträge
kevin hatte dieses jahr schon elf aber
seit einem monat läuft nichts
sein berufsleben besteht zurzeit aus
warten warten auf die toten muss die
sauna und base das rp optimistisch dass
das ende der welt zu einer mit der luft
am abend ist kevin bei seiner mutter zum
essen eingeladen er wohnt allein seit
sie vor einem halben jahr mit ihrem
partner zusammen gezogen ist von anfang
an waren die beiden ein zweierteam levin
kennt seinen vater nicht die berufswahl
ihres sohnes für julian der hygiene
anfangs gewöhnungsbedürftig ist ja nicht
immer nur schön gestorben
eine andere sache und es interessiert
nicht nur futter aus interessiert
liebe deinen kkh ausprobiert deswegen
andere idee
das ist wenn etwas schiefläuft muss sie
gerade stehen
kevin ist nicht mündig und darum nicht
berechtigt die geschäfte abzuschließen
die gesamte verantwortung liegt bei der
mutter auch die finanzielle nicht wieder
ins geschehen meint auch es kann
eigentlich nichts vom staat finanziell
zu stützen
bankkredite
es ist wichtig den verlauf der
hauptsache es eigentlich im rahmen
was braucht sich zieht das ist mir ganz
bewusst wenn man neu startet das
geschäft aufbauen seit drei bis vier
habe schwester songs finanziert ist so
wenig flau
das braucht etwas initiiert und da stand
jetzt einfach kinder waren aber die abis
machen ist sehr schwierig geht es ja
schon job als fußball welt nach auftrag
in motion einfach war besonders eins
spezial ereignisse nur mit der polizei
zusammen der muss schnell und einfach
zweistellige zuwachsraten sind
funktioniert wird ein monat später
treffe ich ihn wieder im altersheim ließ
die tv show ja genau
danke sagen dass sich das fleisch genau
das gründet man sich ja ziemlich
betrieben
denn dieser plötzlich ein auto so können
wir sollten auch in afghanistan bekenne
[Musik]
rücken gestossen wie möglich selbst
einmal damit die gäste setzen
im moment läuft es etwa verdoppelt
ja klar und nehmen im schnitt so hat er
da als nur nach der pause minute davos
50 jahre ist er wisse schon dass ich
solche situation für sich
das ist eine situation braucht man
effektiv und ich sprach
politikverständnis und das modell mit
dieser zurück
er kennt also das ist okay amsterdam sid
oder da ich hoffe ja das ist doch ganz
einfach die besten dank für euer bestes
sommerwetter welche dank für ihre opfer
täter habe zwei gespannt ob das es wert
hier
ob das kunde also zukünftige würden
angehörige oder aber wir bezeugt dass
sie mit ihren zahlen
ja seid ihr sie druckfrisch das macht
sie
im krematorium bern treffe ich einen
bestatter mit erfahrung
daniel meier er arbeitet bei
verschiedenen bestattungsunternehmen
auch bei kevin hogan es ist nicht nur
den arbeit macht war morgen danach diese
laufen und wie viel aber nicht sondern
letztlich immer der stadt unter 60
jahren noch niemand und nichts
poesiealbum gebe beim aufbau spieler
werden oder so
darum der vorsprung und der tat machte
in der b2 euro rief runterfahren
aber das ist natürlich schon so dass je
mehr auftrag dass man miteinander lebt
umso mehr zusätzliche erfahrung und
praktische fragen dazu aber das heißt
nicht dass man mir die realität hätten
aber keine andere stadt darauf an
geschaffen sondern mit ihr nicht heißt
dass man einfach grundsätzlich schlecht
ist und ich danke es gehört genau das
dazu erwarten im behangene junge
menschen zum teil fenster die motivation
einfach nichts machen und das wirklich
mit leib und seele oder weg mit hartz
und und das stück mit kevin und ich
glaube dass die straßen mehr motiviert
wieder ins match erweise sich aber wurde
das wort
kevin hat es nicht leicht sich im
bestand der wissens zu etablieren
besonders wenn ihm zusätzlich noch
kollegen das leben schwer machen
martina fortgang des falls aber doch
weitermachen aber herausgestellt dass
historische geschehen
nur jetzt weniger staat
dass man vorschläge macht die schon
einige dem bett aber wie vor dem auer
machten 32 36 ob der it sparte blöde
gegen widerstände zu kämpfen für kevin
nichts neues er war schon in der schule
ein außenseiter in der fünften
primarklasse entschied seine mutter dass
er auf eine antiautoritäre privatschule
wechseln solle daher gemobbt wurde
herr mixa bestimmt
jetzt zu sagen was tut richtig weh also
herz besitzen ganz ganz starken und ich
habe mir wäre und ja
philippsburg slawische sicher zum
vorteil dieser sache zuletzt im berufs
aber jetzt vor mir muss der kunde also
parallel zwischen robin zieht jetzt ja
parallel hergestellt so viel ausgeben
erklärt alex ikeng zu mensch einzufärben
hatte er wohnt ja schon mal das
alleinige kämpfen
[Musik]
ich bin irritiert und beeindruckt
zugleich wie unbeirrt kevin seinen weg
geht
mit stoischer ruhe
scheinbar gegen alle widrigkeiten um
sein einzugsgebiet zu erweitern würde
eine weitere filiale eröffnet in
grafenried einem berner vorort warum
heiß das sich bei der aktuellen
auftragsflaute noch mehr fixkosten auf
aber das ist natürlich jetzt auch sony
plane die förster usa und das ist schon
wichtig die ringrichter hat das ist ein
bisschen bringen
riskiert mehrheit und das haben wir
nicht noch mal der internetseite
erhältlich oder was ich vor raich
folglich sollte
die sonne
auch den konkurrenten thomas schwab
machen denn es geht
das sehen in dem moment vor
platzhirschen
es ist schon heute abend könnte er diese
platzhirsche treffen beim jährlichen
bestatter essen des krematoriums bern
ob das eine gute idee ist dahin zu gehen
wo man auch mit anwender mit guten nicht
gesperrt so dass ich es interessant aber
nicht um konfrontation zu suchen
das nenne ich hoffe ende das hier aber
nicht kommen aber das ist so wie es auch
in das hoffen dass verbracht worden
mit dem cisco
begleitet wird er an diesem abend von
seinem mitarbeiter daniel meier
das krematorium der stadt bern ist das
einzige krematorium in der region das
hygiene überhaupt erlaubt verstorbene
anzuliefern
für die anderen ist er zu jung und zu
wenig vertrauenswürdig
die das business in den filialen im smi
eingraviert markt seit vier jahren ist
das lächerlich
die gefürchtete konkurrenz ist nicht
gekommen
besteht hier noch vorstellen
versteht sich
wir haben
die geschäftsbanken ihre sich
vernünftigen weg sie ja seit knapp drei
monaten wartet ihr auf den erlösenden
anruf war natürlich gegen trockene
auftrag die umso mehr freuen wenn ihr
die schwangerschaft ist ein grenzenloser
optimist dass da alles burg und muhabbet
optimistisch sieht man schon lange kommt
der luft
so unerwartet wie der tod kommt der lang
ersehnte auftrag die polizei biel hat
kevin aufgeboten
ein mann wurde tot in seiner wohnung
gefunden
zu diesem zeitpunkt ist bereits klar er
starb eines natürlichen todes
darum kann die leiche abgeholt werden
sie wissen da hinzukommen
ich habe
robert diesen auftrag weiter machen kann
entscheiden die angehörigen die sind in
dieser nacht nicht erreichbar
darum bitte tote erst einmal im
krematorium gekühlt am nächsten morgen
steht fest kevin hygiene hat den auftrag
er macht sich mit seinem mitarbeiter
daniel meier auf den weg zur schwester
des verstorbenen nach biel
fließend französisch könnte einfach zwei
jungen die drohnen kompetent beraten
darüber an wieder sehen kann
hygiene ist vielleicht jung aber weise
genug seine grenzen zu erkennen wo seine
erfahrung aufhört setzte auf die
kompetenz von bayern
[Musik]
was kevin hügel genau an diesem beruf
fasziniert ist mir immer noch nicht
wirklich klar aber ich sehe einen jungen
mann der mit leib und seele bei der
sache ist
welcher internat und zwar mit stabilem
augen machen spaß gestartet
ja
wenn sie jetzt neu aufbauen gab es muss
es stimmen im moment um ihr gesicht ist
es dass die verstorbene objekte egal wie
sie sexy was ich glaub das ist mir
wichtig jetzt sucht er strahlend schön
machen
das ist für mich das noch mal machen
während andere in seinem alter noch auf
das richtige leben warten ist kevin
hogan er schon mittendrin und wartet auf
die toten
[Musik]
er versucht sein